en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo hacer un
interruptor de defensa para nuestra
víctima
tenemos los cables conectados a uno y
tres la energía llega a uno y tres y
pueden ver que el led se enciende cuando
aprieto el interruptor y si ahora pongo
la corriente en uno y dos el led se
apaga en lugar de encenderse cuando
aprieto el interruptor así que queremos
conectar los cables en 1 y 3
de todas maneras vamos a verificarlo
otra vez con nuestro multímetro y cuando
colocamos los contactos en 1 y 2 vemos
que se desconecta cuando presiona el
botón y cuando conectamos 1 y 3 se forma
el circuito cuando apretamos el botón
así que queremos conectar uno hay tres
pueden ver que el metal para hacer la
conexión en el interruptor es bastante
corto pueden conseguir estos mini
interruptores en tiendas de electrónica
y en varias tiendas en línea aquí usamos
nuestras pinzas cocodrilo para sostener
el interruptor y ahora vamos a doblar
los contactos 1 y 3 para poder tener una
buena conexión
ahora vamos a enganchar los cables en
nuestras conexiones para que se
sostengan y podamos soldar los sin
problemas aquí yo puse previamente algo
de soldadura para facilitar el hacer las
conexiones
ya tenemos el primer cable en su lugar
ahora vamos a cablear la conexión 3 y la
soldados en su lugar ya que soldamos los
cables vamos a asegurarnos de que la
conexión está bien usando nuestro
multímetro vamos a revisar los extremos
de nuestros cables por lo que pelamos
los extremos y usamos unas pinzas
cocodrilo para conectar los cables a
nuestro multímetro ahora si podemos
asegurarnos de que el interruptor
funciona como debe ser
ahora vamos a quitar la estructura que
rodea a nuestro robot para poder colocar
nuestro interruptor hacemos unos
agujeros y usamos los agujeros que ya
tiene el interruptor como guía para
nuestras perforaciones es importante que
no se perforen los dedos cuando hagan
este tipo de trabajo en espacios
pequeños
así que asegúrense de mantener alejados
sus dedos de la broca colocamos nuestro
interruptor casi en la orilla de nuestra
beats y bot el borde sobresale como
pueden ver es tangente al círculo lo que
es importante para cuando pongamos el
resto de nuestra conexión ponemos
nuestros tornillos al revés para que
podamos colocar de nuevo nuestra bocina
en su lugar de otra manera le estorbaría
lo que sobresale de los tornillos
apretamos los tornillos ayudándonos con
las pinzas de nariz de aguja
aquí usamos cable de cobre de núcleo
sólido de calibre 12 y lo usamos porque
es bastante rígido y nos permitirá
extender el alcance de nuestro
interruptor de botón así que cualquier
cosa con la que se tope nuestra bits y
bot podrá activar nuestro interruptor lo
cual es una mejora en comparación con
nuestro diseño anterior hacemos un
agujero en la parte de atrás en donde
pondremos un tornillo es un tornillo de
metal que nos ayudará a sostener el
elevador que hicimos con el cable y lo
mantendrá en su lugar torcemos el cable
a su alrededor como un caracol y ya que
el cable está en su lugar podemos
doblarla hasta que pueda accionar
debidamente el interruptor esto lo
hacemos a prueba y error pero vale la
pena hacerlo ya que una vez que hayamos
doblado el cable correctamente éste
activará el interruptor cada vez y
extenderá el alcance de éste de manera
que podremos usar un solo interruptor en
lugar de varios
ponemos la tuerca y la apretamos para
dejar el cable en su lugar es importante
que la tuerca y el soporte de arandela
estén bien apretados en su lugar ya que
si el cable se resbala ya no regresará a
su lugar además de que mantendrá
oprimido el interruptor así que por todo
esto es importante que el cable quede
bien apretado para que se mantenga en su
lugar y permita que el interruptor
regrese a su lugar vamos a hacer lo
mismo del otro lado perforamos los
agujeros para este otro interruptor
colocamos nuestras tuercas y tornillos
aunque ahora que me fijo esto está
instalado al revés puse el interruptor
al revés y me di cuenta de esto cuando
comencé a poner el cable verde de cobre
enroscado en el tornillo ya que había
terminado de colocar la tuerca y la
arandela no deja que funcione el
interruptor porque este está al revés
cuando los diseños son muy parecidos a
veces es fácil confundirse y colocar las
cosas al revés aquí quito el interruptor
y los volteo para dejarlo en la posición
correcta para que la palanca del
interruptor quede por fuera del círculo
y tangente a este para que cuando el
extensor del interruptor o este cable
verde se comprima active el interruptor
y permita que el robot cambie su
dirección o realice otras funciones
diferentes nuevamente es importante
apretar muy bien el extremo del cable en
su lugar
estos interruptores los pueden conseguir
en cualquier tienda que venda partes
electrónicas y no son caros
ahora vamos a cablear los interruptores
tomamos dos de los cables uno de cada
interruptor y nos vamos a conectar en la
terminal positiva de nuestro circuito
provisional que usamos para distribuir
la energía distinguimos la terminal
positiva porque tiene un signo de más y
tiene conectado a un cable rojo aquí
conectamos los cables de nuestros
interruptores para que nuestros
interruptores tengan energía ya que
conectamos nuestros cables a la terminal
positiva revisamos nuestro diseño
inicial para codificar y vemos que
nuestros interruptores de defensa tienen
que conectarse a a4 y a5
el de atrás es a 5 y el de enfrente es a
4 estas conexiones analógicas 4 y 5 se
encuentran del otro lado de nuestra
tarjeta de prototipos están entre 24 y
30 en nuestra tarjeta de prototipos
pelamos los extremos de los cables que
son los que vienen de nuestros
interruptores del otro lado pelamos los
extremos de los cables que son los que
vienen de nuestro interruptor del otro
lado y antes de conectarlos vamos a usar
nuestras resistencias de 10 kilos que
nos van a ayudar a limitar la corriente
vamos a conectar el cable del
interruptor a un lado de la resistencia
de 10 kilos en cada uno de ellos y ahora
conectaremos el otro lado de la
resistencia a nuestro cable de tierra
ahora cortamos los cables de tierra y
pelamos los extremos de estos cables
estos cables los conectamos del lado
negativo de nuestro circuito provisional
debajo del arduino vamos a acomodarlo y
ponerlos alrededor para llevarlos a la
misma ubicación en nuestra tarjeta de
prototipos donde se encuentran nuestras
resistencias de 10 kilos pelamos estos
otros extremos y los conectamos en el
mismo renglón pero del otro lado de
nuestras resistencias ahora ya estamos
listos para configurar nuestro arduino
ahora vamos a conectar a 5 y a 4 en los
mismos renglones que los de los cables
verdes que ya teníamos aquí que son los
cables de nuestros interruptores nuestro
circuito está listo para usar los
interruptores de defensa este es el
momento de verificar el que todas las
cosas funcionen como deben ser aunque
antes de eso es mejor que coloquemos de
nuevo nuestra bocina tuvimos que quitar
la de su lugar para poder colocar los
interruptores de defensa perforar los
agujeros para los tornillos que quedaron
debajo del lugar donde va el interruptor
ahora la volvemos a colocar en su lugar
esta es una de las grandes ventajas del
silicon caliente que podemos despegarlo
con facilidad si queremos y ahora si
probamos que funcione el dispositivo
vemos que todo está encendido tenemos
algo de código programado en nuestro
arduino para que al activarse los
interruptores de defensa se detengan los
motores
lo hace correctamente el código lo
tendrán disponible en nuestros vídeos
sobre el arduino publicaremos su liga
cuando tengamos listos estos vídeos